[Music]  okay  that's edgy stuff there i mean the guy's  got the fingernails painted black and  everything  i remember when kids did that when i was  in middle school to prove how rebellious  they were and we called them goths back  then they call them something else now  but really the word that that binds them  all together would be uh dorks  dorks by another name  real tough guy by the way covering his  face while he does this  all these people who hate america what  do they really hate  and i'll tell you they hate themselves  that's what they actually hate they are  they are dissatisfied with who they are  and with their own lives and they've  projected those feelings of resentment  and uh and failure on to on to the  entire country  trump and the usa  in this case with these people the self  should be the problem  uh they should be dissatisfied with  themselves because they are miserable  losers after all